>>> THIS MORNING WE'RE LEARNING
MORE ABOUT THE SURPRISING
HOLLYWOOD ORIGIN OF A GESTURE
USED BY DEMONSTRATORS IN
SOUTHEAST ASIA WHO ARE
PROTESTING AUTHORITARIAN RULE.
THE SIMPLE THREE-FINGERED SALUTE
HAS UNITED DEMONSTRATORS IN
COUNTRIES LIKE MYANMAR, FORMERLY
KNOWN AS BURMA.
HOLLY WILLIAMS SHOWS THE SOURCE
AND WHAT THE GESTURE SIGNAL
ABOUT THE POWER OF AMERICAN
CULTURE.
[ CHEERS ]
>> Reporter: IN ASIA, THIS IS A
GESTURE OF COURAGE US ON
DEFIANCE.
A CHALLENGE TO REPRESSIVE
GOVERNMENTS THAT CUTS ACROSS
BORDERS.
IT'S USED IN MYANMAR --
[ GUNFIRE ]
WHERE PROTESTERS AGAINST A
MILITARY COUP ARE BEING MURDERED
IN COLD BLOOD.
[ SIREN ]
IN THAILAND WHERE THEY'RE
DEMANDING FULL DEMOCRACY.
[ CHANTS ]
AND IN HONG KONG WHERE YEARS OF
PROTESTS AGAINST INTERFERENCE BY
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT HAVE
DRAWN MILLIONS ON TO THE
STREETS.
>> THAT CULTURAL SYMBOL REALLY
BECOMES A UNIVERSAL LANGUAGE.
>> Reporter: NATHAN LAW IS A
PRO-DEMOCRACY LEADER FROM HONG
KONG WHO AVOIDED ARREST BY
FLEEING TO LONDON.
>> THAT THREE-FINGER SIGNATURE,
IT SYMBOLIZES A REVOLUTIONARY
STANCE OF PEOPLE.
>> Reporter: REVOLUTIONARY
STANCE?
>> YES, YES, WE WANTED TO HAVE
FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
>> Reporter: IF THE
THREE-FINGERED SALUTE SEEMS
FAMILIAR TO YOU, YOU PROBABLY
SAW IT HERE.
"THE HUNGER GAMES" FILMS.
SET IN A POST-APOCALYPTIC WORLD
WHERE THE POWERLESS RAISE THEIR
HANDS IN RESISTANCE TO A
TYRANNICAL REGIME.
THE FILMS EARNED MORE THAN $3
BILLION WORLDWIDE.
IF IT SEEMS FRIVOLOUS TO LINK A
LIFE AND DEATH FIGHT FOR FREEDOM
TO A BLOCKBUSTER HOLLYWOOD MOVIE
FRANCHISE, THEN THINK AGAIN.
>> PEOPLE IMMEDIATELY --
>> Reporter: KYAW WIN TELL US
THEY'RE USING THE SFYMBOL TO DRW
ATTENTION TO AMERICA.
>> WE'RE SENDING THE
THREE-FINGER MESSAGE TO THE
PEOPLE OF U.S. AND THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT TO HELP US, TO HELP
US.
THIS IS INSPIRATION COME FROM
YOU AND NOW WE ARE SACRIFICING
OUR LIFE EVERY DAY, HELP US.
>> Reporter: THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
MOST OFTEN USING THE
THREE-FINGER SALUTE, IT IS
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT SPEAK.
>> Reporter: NINA JACOBSON
PRODUCED "THE HUNGER GAMES"
FILMS.
>> IT'S A REMINDER OF THE
RESPONSIBILITY WE HAVE AND THE
IMAGERY WE CREATE.
BUT ALSO I GUESS TO TRY TO LIVE
UP TO THE VALUES IN OUR OWN
DEMOCRACY THAT WE DON'T ALWAYS
MANAGE TO -- WE HAVEN'T BEEN AS
SUCCESSFUL.
>> Reporter: COULD YOU EVER HAVE
IMAGINED, THOUGH, THAT THE FILMS
WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT LIKE THIS
IN REAL LIFE?
>> NO.
IT'S AN HONOR.
>> Reporter: AMERICA'S
STAGGERING POWER COMES NOT JUST
FROM ITS MILITARY AND ITS MONEY
BUT FROM ITS CULTURE.
HOLLYWOOD MAY BE DRIVEN BY
PROFITS, BUT IT ALSO CREATES ART
THAT INSPIRES US AND CONNECTS
US.
>> THAT PENETRATION OF THE MOVIE
ACTUALLY HELPS US TO HAVE A
COMMON LANGUAGE.
WHENEVER THEY RAISE THAT
GESTURE, WE UNDERSTAND IT
BECAUSE WE HAVE WATCHED A
MICHIGANMOVIE
AND THAT IS THE BEAUTY OF IT.
>> Reporter: HOLLY WILLIAMS,
LONDON.
>> AMAZING POWER IN A SIMPL